[Music]
we're here for the opening ceremony of
the inaugural parent's cup an exciting
new tournament on the st. Louis calendar
[Music]
it's my honor to welcome all of you
wonderful players to st. Louis and when
you get to see the place and get to
enjoy it I want you to know that I've
talked to the mayor I've got connections
you're all welcome to move here my maid
name is Karen's as and my all my
children are named their middle name is
Karen's so that's where the Karen's
comes from it's a Scottish name it means
a pile of rocks this will maybe a be
just like the Ziegfeld Cup but better
classic those are fighting words trash
talking in that household we all agree
with this ethos that we need to
introduce more girls and went into this
incredible game that teaches so many
life skills and that's why tonight I'm
also proud to announce a partnership
between the st. Louis chess club and us
chess women that includes $100,000
commitment from the club to promote
girls and women in u.s. chess with the
generous gift just announced from the
st. Louis chess club in support of the
u.s. chess women and girls initiative we
will strive to provide a welcoming
environment for girls and women so that
they too can realize their potential
across the board and beyond I'm really
happy to be here to be a part of such a
strong tournament and I'm really excited
so I'll try to show some interesting
games and new ideas I've always heard
about the hospitality of st. Louis and
of course the organization and
everything so when I heard about this
and I really wanted to be part of it I
hope we will deliver a lot of exciting
games and I bet that the drawing right
in women's tournament anyway is much
lower in comparison to the men's so I
bet that you will not get bored like of
20 moves draws so I guess everybody in
our tournament is able to win this
tournament which will make it much more
exciting a lot of these ladies I've
known for like a decade or two and I've
just never had the chance to compete in
a tournament like this before so
I'm really looking forward to I'm
delighted to find out that it's like the
beginning of a new chest tradition for
women's chess and I think it's wonderful
I hope you will continue to organize
women and such a high level tournaments
in the future because I think it is very
important for us for professional chess
boom in chess players
[Music]
that was a fantastic evening the
pairings have been drawn and we're going
to have an exciting tournament